I discourage any discussion of
impeachment on a political side I think
it's a gift to the Republicans to talk
about impeachment the last thing this
country needs is impeachment proceedings
that move forward as a matter of course
because we don't like the president you
can't jump the gun and determine that
somebody should be in peace when you're
going to be voting on on the impeachment
issue it's too early to talk about
impeachment they're all lying the entire
Democratic Party base wants the
president impeached John Nichols right
rights for the nation excuse me it's
sort of peace asking why are so many
Democrats afraid of impeachment John
Nichols joins us to me John I don't
think I agree with you on much normally
I'd be here arguing with you but I'm
just gonna give you a sincere company I
thought your piece was honest this is
the constitutionally prescribed remedy
for a president you think has gone off
the rails I don't believe that you do
but impeachment is the answer Democrats
support it why are the leaders of the
Democratic Party not willing to admit
that I think they're playing a political
game and I think that you assume that
they would impeach if they got power I'm
not sure of that I think that there is a
tepid miss about using impeachment as a
live instrument of the Constitution
holding a president who has as you
suggest gone off the rails who I would
suggest abuses the office to account and
but clearly at this point there's a
tremendous pressure on members of the
party and on folks to not talk about
impeachment my sense is that's very
problematic because if you are saying
that the President of the United States
has abused his office if you are
suggesting that he is doing things that
are clearly impeachable but then you say
well but let's not talk about
impeachment that that creates an
unreality to the discourse and I think
frankly it's it's it's not appropriate I
think that that a discussion of
impeachment is healthy I think it's
necessary but be it's also it's also
something that I think politicians of
both parties tend to fear too much it's
above what I
about it again I'm not for it but it's
aboveboard it takes place in public and
people can make their public arguments
and what they're doing instead is
subverting entire federal agencies and
liberals should be worried about this
law enforcement and Intel agencies to do
their bidding why do that if you have a
case be a man about it
say what it is voters can assess if
that's what impeachment is that's why
the founders put it in the founding
documents so why would the leaders of
the party pretend oh that's off the
table it just seems so feline and
dishonest again I'm not sure they're
pretending Tucker we will see if
Democrats get control of the house
whether they would move on it but
remember that back in the George W Bush
presidency there was a significant
agitation at the grassroots of the
Democratic Party and frankly Beyond and
among a lot of folks for impeachment of
President Bush Nancy listen came to
power
she can't I know you do because you
actually what followed it Nancy Pelosi
came to power in 2007 and one of her
first signals was off the table and so
this is this is a complexity on this
issue now where it goes back to I think
you and I both know is the the Clinton
impeachment and there's a sense that the
Clinton impeachment led to political
repercussions for Republicans in fact if
you look at it the repercussions were
not as great as some people assume but I
always remind folks that if you look at
the Nixon impeachment which obviously
wasn't brought to fruition but was a
very serious moment there weren't
political repercussions for the
Democrats in that and so I do think that
that we have a lot of politicians on
both sides Republicans and Democrats who
avoid accountability moments and and
frankly avoid opening up the discussions
when I should be doing so exactly
they're avoiding accountability and I
and I have to say again I don't think I
agree with you on anything including
what to order for dinner but I
appreciate the honesty of the actual
left in this case trying to hold your
party not mine yours to some account
into honesty so thank you John for doing
that we're not a backhanded captured
sincere one thanks I appreciate it
Tucker and I think I won't get any Pat's
on the back for it no you definitely
okay